here to discuss the political fallout
from the Moller report and more is Anita
Kumar White House correspondent and
associate editor at Politico and need a
good morning good morning
we've got Jerry Nadler the head of the
House Judiciary Committee subpoenaing
the full report indicating that he might
want to hold extensive hearings on all
of this calling Miller weird where
exactly are we going at this point well
it's not over that we know well I mean
obviously the Democrats want the full
report and they've been saying that from
the beginning and they're gonna continue
to try to work to get it but to get that
they're going to have to go to court to
try to get a judge to allow them to have
all the pieces of that report and the
the pieces that they didn't get were
where the grand jury met and and and
talked about things so they could go to
a court and try to do that I mean it's
just gonna be a prolonged fight at this
point this obviously is falling on party
lines as we're seeing the reactions to
it what about I feel like we always go
to the Trump base nothing seems to make
a difference and even just that idea
that he didn't commit a crime but he's
not exonerated when it comes to
obstruction any impact on the Trump base
at this point when you can add one each
one not that I've seen at all I mean
what they're saying and what the talking
points are and what we're hearing is
that they say he didn't do it so it
vindicates him in that he's been saying
for two years people are out to get me
Democrats are out to get me the media is
out to get me you know the deep states
out to get me and this just proves that
for him right he's saying I was right
two years they've wasted all this time
and it's money now there is the piece of
obstruction but they'll say well there
was no underlying crime so he tried to
do what you know and so they'll just as
the man we own write him to be alright
right and remember when Democrats push
back and continue keeping this going for
the next two years they're gonna say
Democrats are overreaching and so
they're they think that they'll look
good this you know the way they want to
today in this point contextualizing this
a bit in terms of history how is this
really different from what Richard Nixon
did in the 70s and Bill Clinton in the
90s well why don't what reason it's
different is because we can see a lot
more right I mean it's just the the
modern day today but you're right I mean
people have could people have compared
it to what has been done in the past but
the president keeps going back to this
if there was no underlying
then how can i how can I be committed
you know commit have committed
obstruction in and you know because Bob
Muller didn't go there it's a question
of what what we do next now you'll see
what Congress says Congress says now
it's in our court we have to decide if
there was obstruction so the question of
I mean that Democrats there are
divisions already on whether they should
seek impeachment or not
how big a fight is there going to be
within the Democratic Party I think
you're already seeing it you saw House
Majority Leader Leader Steny Hoyer say
you know no impeachment and then he
walked that back because he got a lot of
criticism for that from people in his
party so you're seeing as you saw
Elizabeth Warren saying let's look at
that you see a lot of you know more
progressives saying we've got to look at
impeachment you're seeing House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi saying let's wait and see
what what the Republican Senate and no
real hope of impeachment ultimately
what's the cost of Democrats if they if
they try to go this really that's why
Nancy Pelosi is saying we can't do this
unless we have the support of
Republicans what's the point and they
were afraid of the backlash you know
when they when they're up in 2020 not
the presidential race their race if all
they've done is go after who Donald
Trump and they have done nothing else
it's gonna hurt them yeah and we'll hear
from Nancy Pelosi on Monday obviously
out of the country and saying she didn't
want to speak on it at that point I need
a thank you sure thank you